hallo meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen folge von
minecraft guide wir befinden uns gerade
in der dritten folge und ich habe wieder
drei effekt rausgesucht plus eins
anfängt auch dieses mal
letztes mal habe ich irgendwie vergessen
weil ich zeit vergessen habe da hinten
toten schaf rum und ihr seht schon in
die erste veränderung ich habe die welt
ein wenig anders aufgebaut und zwar habe
ich mir jetzt mal selbst hier sowas
zusammengestellt um euch dass selbst ein
bisschen zeigen zu können
ich finde eigentlich ganz gut also die
welt in ihren von jjw in schönefeld kann
nicht am start weil ich gerade ja warum
eigentlich nicht keine ahnung ich wollte
ich habe gesagt ich mache dir manchmal
und hierfür ist jetzt nicht unbedingt
notwendig um eine reaktion zu sehen da
ist ein sehr sachliches video ist jetzt
wieder fleißig sachen geschrieben sieht
wo er das kind programm von jetzt im
total kaputt das wird einfach nicht mehr
geredet für die 1.5 und so
deswegen kann ich keine skins von euch
mal an zu erwecken wir weiter infekt sie
kommentare schreiben und ich habe halt
wieder drei sachen mit einem perfekt um
die erste sache ist dass ein creeper die
explosion bis zum der countdown bis
explosion dauert in einem spinnennetz
länger als normal und dafür habe ich
jetzt einfach mal rechts eingeblendet
einen normalen kritik schlag und hier so
einen über den schlager dann schlage ich
jetzt einfach mal
okay das war eine relativ große
explosion also ziemlich klar irgendwie
ich weiß nicht ob die spinnennetze
darauf auch einfluss haben auf die
explosion allerdings habt ihr schon
gesehen dass auf jeden fall die
explosion hier beim vollen bild wo wir
uns jetzt gerade wieder befinden im
wesentlich länger gedauert hat als bei
dem normalen bild rechts und das war auf
jeden fall erstmal die erste sache so
kommen jetzt auch direkt zur zweiten
sache und zwar wenn man zombies und
skelette natürlich hier hinsetzt und es
ist tag dann brennen die natürlich
direkt genau das gleiche was glätten
die machen jetzt eine kleine brennen
party ist der sommer da könnte geringer
herkommt stärkt also nach derzeit
sterben auf die kriegen natürlich auch
schaden versuchen dann möglichst schnell
sich in kienbaum zu suchen oder enkel
hinzugehen wo schatten ist das skelett
versucht da wahrscheinlich runter zu
kommen wo es hat sogar geschafft an der
trend immer noch weiter auch die sonne
hinkommt
aber ihr wisst denke ich was ich meine
also die fangen an zu brennen wenn man
allerdings zombie zb als haustier halten
möchte oder skelette dann setzt man sich
einfach auf souls ändern können die
tagsüber auch nicht brennen also die
kondition haben so viel sie wollen die
bremer noch nicht wenn sie allerdings
moment da auf diesem kleinen rand hier
schon sind dann fangen sie an zu brennen
wenn sie dann wieder zurück auf den cent
gehen dann löscht es dir auch nicht also
setzt nicht so wie wasser das er dann
einfach da reingehen können dann stoppt
das halt das stop nämlich erst nach
einer relativ langen zeit dass sie
kriegen erst noch weiter steigen und
danach zu trennen gute stück hat der
zombie daten nicht aufhört zu brennen
mitbekommen und das gehört jetzt auch
wieder als handy halten wollte dann
einfach in summe sowie cent käfig und
york das war die zweite sache so kommen
wir nun weiter zur dritten sache die ich
euch heute vorstellen möchte und somit
auch gleich zur letzten richtigen
änderungen die änderung kann gar nicht
sagen zum letzten richtigen fällt also
der ich wirklich was bringen sagt nicht
mal und zwar kennt sie alle wenn ihr bei
schafen rechts macht dieter scheerer
dann geht auch eure geht auch eure
schere so ein bisschen dabei kaputt weil
ihr können dass er selber wenn die
schafe zur apathie jeder jeder kurve
kann auch eine schwere nehmen müssen
schneiden und dann geht eure schere
natürlich auch die blätter dann ein
bisschen ab allerdings wenn man mit der
schere wolle blöcke abort seht ihr das
schon unten drin
in meiner schnellauswahl leiste das geht
nicht kaputt also
wenn ihr euch das jetzt mal so
vorstellen wenn ihr mit länder ganz
normal mit der hand wolle blöcke abbaut
dann dauert das ja eine gewisse zeit ist
es vorstellen aber es dauert eine
gewisse zeit genau das gleiche ist auch
bei erde eure hand kann natürlich nicht
kaputt gehen wenn man allerdings eine
schaufel nimmt die dafür sorgt dass man
die erde schneller abbauen kann dann
geht die schaufel kaputt allerdings wenn
man eine schere nimmt um wolle schneller
abbauen zu können geht die schere nicht
kaputt irgendwie so ein bisschen
selbstironisch finde ich ein bisschen
komisch ist aber so und ihr seht die
scharade keine gebrauchsspuren ich kann
jetzt einfach eine schere nehmen und mal
eben so ein paar schafe hier scheren so
habe ich auf jeden fall ist mal ein
bisschen wolle und meine schere ist
jetzt auch benutzt und ist jetzt dieser
komische balken wenn ich jetzt
allerdings wieder ein paar blöcke hier
wieder welche sieht er hier so ein paar
blöcke abbauen da gegner kein bisschen
von der schere runter wenn ich jetzt
allerdings wieder schafe scheren werde
du wirst auch hier gleich bestimmt
irgendwas essen oder du bist doch gleich
gestimmt für roma da will ich doch all
das war fällig zwar habe geht die
haltbarkeit wieder runter deshalb nicht
gesehen weil es relativ wenig war aber
die haltbarkeit geht halt runter wenn
die schere shell wenn ihr schaf ist aber
wenn ihr wolle blöcke so abbaut geht die
haltbarkeit nicht runter bisschen
selbstironisch ist aber sowieso nun zur
sache auf die alle gewartet haben und
zwar der zahnfee was dreht sich das rad
weg danke dass du ja immer und zwar der
fun facts und was scharfes liga pink
egal kommt zum konter
die haut ab alle kühe in minecraft sind
grundsätzlich weiblich nicht weil die
leute kennen fünftes wein haben sondern
bei ein fachmann von allen man bekommt
von allen bühnen milch egal bei welcher
kooperativ zu zeigen und ein paar mehr
ein
egal auf welche kuh ich gehe ich krieg
von jeder kuh grundsätzlich immer milch
weil sie natürlich heute hat und eine
männliche coo von täglich war natürlich
keine milch wären hat biologie
aufgepasst hat der weiß natürlich dass
er stimmt und ich trinke jetzt noch ein
bisschen milch ich würde sagen das war's
dann erstmal vom heutigen minecraft
geleitet vom heutigen der letztes jahr
eine woche her oder so der kommt er
nicht täglich und zwar wie immer wenn es
euch gefallen dann würde ich mich über
einen daumenbruch freund schaffen wir
1000 daumen hoch dass wir auf jeden fall
seine nummer war oder würde ich schon
erstmal meine zunge runterschlucken und
sterben nach hin würde ich mich freuen
und schreiben doch wenn die kommentare
weitere fun facts wo ihr denkt hey
kommen die könnte mir vorstellen die
ihnen weiß ich zwar bei den wissen
bestimmt wieder andere leute nicht
und dann würde ich einfach sagen ich geh
jetzt ein paar kühe schlachten und paar
schweine und pferde dann wieder sanieren
und dann würde ich einfach sagen um
deren menge tropfen lassen
dann würde ich einfach sagen wir sehen
uns dann beim nächsten mal ich wünsche
euch noch wunderschöne ferien und ich
gehe wieder zu meiner mond